not only that let's just back up and
talk about your dad just for a second
this was this was something that i
learned
about your parents the first time we
talked so you are you are one of 10
siblings but your parents adopted how
many kids
um
they adopted three they gave one up
there you go man so your parents are
your parents are good people so they
have three adopted kids i think six or
seven of their own
what was your home and we'll get back to
your red pill origins what was your
upbringing like uh two-parent home talk
to me about your home life as a kid
um
okay yeah my so i grew up one of six i
was the second out of the six i was the
oldest girl i grew up between two boys
oh wow
yeah so in when i was growing up there
was six kids in the house everywhere we
would go with six
um
i didn't
and we would always have a nanny so we
did like my parents did have help okay
um and they were typically like german
okay um i don't not that that's that
relevant but yeah
so now they were german nannies were
they uh were they german american like
they were americanized or were they
actually like from germany
it's called opera in america so it's a
program
yeah so i grew up um like we probably
had 20 plus lot pairs we would get a new
one every year wow okay that's
interesting so my my dad was gone a lot
growing up okay so i will say a lot of
people want this lifestyle but they
don't they don't know what it comes with
right and everything and everything that
you get in life has a cost so it was
really funny to me watching people like
talk about how they want this lifestyle
and i'm like look at like if you're that
successful you're gonna miss a part of
your kid's childhood yes
yes yes like
i say this all the time pearl everybody
wants to be don't get me wrong there's
nothing wrong with success and being a
high earner but there's a cost for
everything if you're a man and you're
going to be a ceo or if you're going to
be a high level guy got to understand if
you're not home a lot your your kids
probably aren't going to like you too
much and your wife's probably going to
have an affair
i mean you'll probably have an affair or
two this is just the cost of success so
it's good that you understand hey you
know what if i'm going to be this boss
[ __ ] or this boss dude there are costs
to that i mean interrupt but go ahead no
you're fine you're you're absolutely
right he worked 80 hours a week probably
my whole life yeah my dad is the hardest
worker i've ever met um
and i really didn't know him at all
until i was like
16 to be honest really and now and the
way i look at it like some people this
happens to like i've met other kids with
such like similar situations they get
mad and like resent their dad but the
way i look at it is like he did that and
now i can hang out with him as much as i
possibly want okay so he's retired
obviously yeah so i can if i wanted to i
could go like he let me live with him
for a year like i can see him all i want
now oh wow wow yeah but um
yeah so
growing up like it was cool and like i
had a really good childhood
my mom and dad like probably they were
around as much as they could they never
missed the big dance but when it came to
like being driven to like school or like
whatever that was always done by like an
annie okay very